foreign
I just got this uh at the break from our
real estate team uh inventory on real
estate is increasing year over year at a
higher rate and is still well below
historical averages we still have a
housing shortage even though number of
homes for sales increase 67 percent over
last year the total number of unsold
homes including homes that are under
contract is increased only by 13
interesting newly listed homes are well
below historical averages
and we are at 15.9 percent fewer homes
being listed compared to last year the
median price of homes for sale
has increased
7.8 percent in February
lower than January's growth rate okay
but we're up housing prices nationally
up January up February much like we
predicted yes when we did the real
estate live stream last fall we told you
there was going to continue to be a
shortage we're going to see a seven to
an eight percent increase in prices in
2023 and we are currently tracking for
7.8 percent
and homes are spending 67 days on the
market which is 23 days longer than last
year but still shorter than most times
in history when they run 90 to 120 days
I mean if you want to compare the market
to Crazy Town which was 2020 and 2021
were things I remember when we sold our
house I mean the timing to be a Ramsey
personality moved from Miami was
incredible well our real estate agent
was apologizing because we only had
eight offers yeah
you know it's like sorry we didn't get
you know that day the day of the open
house sorry you know we only had four
today and only only four the next day so
translation if you're not putting your
home on the market because you think the
market is slow you're statistically
speaking wrong
if you're not putting your home on the
market because you're thinking the real
estate market is down
statistically speaking on a national
average you're wrong
great time to sell a house when the
house when the when there's a housing
shortage we have more houses for sale
than we did this time last year but
again we're still coming out the back of
Crazy Town last year right so we we're
we're returning to a more normal level
of inventory with still more buyers than
sellers
still
even with high interest rates but the
interest rates do not drive the market
as much as Supply demand drives the
market
meaning meaning the prices are going to
go up as long as there are more buyers
than sellers there's a housing shortage
you're always going to see price that's
why we've got an 8 7.8 price increase or
schedule I mean that's what we're
tracking for annually now it's not 32
percent during Crazy Town right
and that's what people can't get used to
so
um
Megan Kelly's podcast the other day
she's been a friend a long time and she
said so what do you mean I said well
Megan it's like if you're driving your
car like 90 or 100 miles an hour and
then you slow down to 45 it feels like
you're you're like you're crawling yeah
and she goes I've never had that feeling
that's funny she I think she obeys the
law but yeah there you go so um I just
feel like we have short memories
as as as American people our memory is
is We compare We compare
not to historical distance you're right
but into what the last thing I felt last
like Friday that's what it is we're
basing it on pure emotion and are we you
know what are we hearing on the uh God
awful news channel right yeah that's
what it is just telling us our world's
coming to an end world's coming to an
end if you didn't know the world's
coming to an end and you're going to die
of a tornado too by the way I just think
that's a problem though when we we're
listening to a talking head tell us
something contrary to what our own
experience is telling us what our own
memory should tell us and the reason I
put these this data out when I got the
email at the break I thought you know
John deloney talks about facts yep are
your friends yep when you have fear or
you're worried or whatever facts are
your friends in the middle of an
emergency situation stop and analyze the
facts facts are your friends what's the
real situation here and what you're most
of the time run into when you do that is
it calms you down and you say I'm not
going to sweat the small stuff and most
everything that I'm worried about is
small stuff in the scope of your life
yeah